what is the best state in the U.S oh
that's Florida it's a great great stage
did you travel that much to other states
not at all you said really I think uh
before the show you said you've been to
like Texas and stuff right yeah Texas is
nice I really like Texas Texas is like a
Florida with better weather is that the
photos no I've been out of the country
once I went to Canada when I was a kid
it's not like a store I mean I guess
it's a cool story I went skiing on the
same Hill that Liam Neeson's wife died
on
but I went there like a year before it
happened oh right that's not a cool
story I guess yeah
and then they won't let you back into
Canada they did now I can't go back yeah
yeah I mean do you ever talk about
because obviously I think it's well
known that you've like a fear of flying
yeah do you talk about that much no only
when it comes up I just don't fly how
did that like fear develop I guess
how did it all start yeah I don't know
when Matt started but the other day I
told the the group here I'm also like a
legitimate hypochondriac and I know
exactly where that started my doctor
before I went to high school made a big
song and dance out of the meningitis
shot because you needed it to go to the
high school okay and I was like up until
this point I was pretty Carefree I'd
like to eat worms I'd jump in lakes and
then my doctor when he was told to give
me the meningitis shot he's like I'm not
doing that it's gonna paralyze your son
like your son's gonna die from this is
like a crazy doctor he was fine all the
way up until this point he told me he
said that in front of me and I was like
what does he mean mom um he's gonna is
this gonna kill me and so I went home
and I'm like Googling these things yeah
it was horrifying I Googled all these
things about like the side effect like
Gillian Parr syndrome or something where
I guess is what he was talking about was
he like some kind of like conspiracy he
must have been and then from that point
forward I was afraid of everything I
still got the shot but I was afraid to
[ __ ] traumatized yeah he legitimately
gave me hypochondria for life to be fair
if a doctor tells you yeah at a young
age how old are you in that it was right
before high school I would have been
going on that would have scared though
yeah [ __ ] me off I hadn't thought
about that for years until the other day
I brought it up to the team I was like
that's absolutely where that started
damn that's totally understandable I
don't know where the plane stuff started
though I remember watching Phoenix
Flight of the Phoenix when I was a kid
where the plane crashes in the desert
and they kill each other yeah [ __ ]
that's sick irony
that could be me
damn yeah because I mean like you know
you obviously love so much like you know
Japanese like you know media and content
stuff like that like I'm sure there's
somewhere in your head where you're like
I really [ __ ] want to know suck it
off and go to Japan right
down this is such a long flight 12 hours
I'd be like an anesthesiologist to keep
me
what I'm hearing is if there's somewhere
that you can get there like while being
drunk I think it'd be great like I think
it'd be a really fun trip
you'd have a field day with all the [ __ ]
you can find them oh my God it is an
absolute content gold mine yeah
especially for you like you'd find so
much weird [ __ ] we've all been talking
about it too like we've all wanted to
make that trip it's just for me it's
[ __ ] hard yeah yeah if it's like a
fear it's a fear right yeah not sure
someone would be like yeah obviously I
know it's not gonna crash but it's like
I don't think that I think it's I I hate
it I don't want to be up there you know
yeah I mean it doesn't matter how many
like you know little information tidbits
of like oh if you didn't die in the car
crash on the way to the airport and
you've survived is
don't be scared Charlie come on oh my
God you're putting yourself in danger
more every single day in a car than you
are on a plane and it's like okay yeah
easier said than done right yeah yeah
cause a lot of people would ask us all
the time like when are you gonna get
Charlie I'm like well you know we have a
very strict policy it has to be in
person yeah people just wouldn't shut
the [ __ ] up about it yeah and we're like
so we have to make our way
Charlie he made us come all the way to
Tampa Florida
it's awesome being here but no I mean
like it's yeah it's a lot
you know and it's it's like you couldn't
you couldn't be further from Japan I'm
just praying for like another Pangea
where everything comes
I just don't want to be close to Florida
are you kidding me no you make the drive
across yeah the hell drive across even
it's like a five-day drive on land
Florida just breaks off from the rest of
America and floats its way towards Asia
so do you ever think like do you ever
get like a bit Shady like [ __ ] I'll
probably never like see Europe yeah like
I do think about that I'm not like a big
outdoorsy guy like yeah seeing sites is
cool but it's not something like top of
mind all right but with Japan in
particular it's like so many things that
I know are like exclusive to there that
I won't be able to do if I don't go yeah
so that one's like actually tough that
in Sweden Sweden seems like another
really cool spot why Sweden like dream
hacking everything everything like it
just seemed like a really cool spot with
a lot of stuff to do yeah that makes
sense where's the furthest you have
traveled in is it Canada just Canada
okay yeah it was nice yeah you drove
there right soon no I actually flew no
it's my four years yeah no like I was
scared then too but like I have sucked
it up and flown I flew to Dallas like
two months ago now but it's it's just
really it's hard yeah yeah I know
there's a few friends of mine where it's
like um
they have to like they will fly but it's
like they have to do like 50 things
before just to like calm themselves if
they don't do all of those things they
won't get on the plane Jesus and it'll
be like weird things it'll be like you
know you have to wear the right pair of
socks because that's what they've
convinced themselves right like that's
that's and it's obviously they they and
it's not like they've done they know
that it's irrational and they know that
it doesn't make sense they just can't do
anything but in your mind it's just like
you just you you think that like you
have to do this and if you don't do it
you're not comfortable yeah and even
then getting on the plane is terrifying
or like doing a certain thing or going
going to the dogs getting the shot it's
like it's different for everyone our
minds are [ __ ] weird yeah yeah they
do not work well I'm not anti-backs by
the way
I get all my shots just fine it's just
hypochondria with germs and meningitis
and my University someone died she's
from meningitis really yeah because they
didn't get the shot oh [ __ ] and I was
like oh I'm glad I took this because
they tell you it's oh it's super serious
and you're like talking head of this
disease yeah why is no one talking about
it someone at my University got measles
yeah we had a guy get measles I think
it's gonna see a big uptick it's coming
it's coming back unfortunately measles
is on the camera oh man those stocks are
up it's it's it's sad yeah it is
you're going to be seeing the bibronic
plague I think we'll be fine down here
though like we we're tough
we'll be fine Linda you're like the New
York rats right like it's like you
developed so well but it's like oh god
what happened you're like it's like
impossible to get rid of you you're like
what have we created like cockroaches
like just survive yeah
bro British people could not survive
hurricanes and [ __ ] like that and floods
but we're done we're done at the sun is
out like we're like [ __ ] you guys have
like Darkness for most of the time right
like it's always rainy rainy and clown
it's mostly gray actually I've realized
this the other day
um when I was back in England and it was
raining I was depressed and I realized I
like that you you love that but I
realized only in England do I find rain
really depressing in a lot of other
places I kind of like dig it it kind of
like it's kind of like a Vibe sometimes
it fits in Japan I kind of like I kind
of like the rain in Japan but that's
because everything in Japan is aesthetic
that's that's true that's true well I
should ask why all the Lo-Fi goes with
it man yeah exactly looking around if
you're in Tokyo and it starts raining
you just put some Lo-Fi on and you
that's a Vibe now yeah you can't do that
in England yeah you'll have a clear
umbrella as well the clear umbrella so
you can see the rain dude
that's the jam right there oh my God
have you ever tried learning another
language I'm curious I tried learning
Japanese I took an entire semester in
college really yep it didn't go super
well
I can only remember a few things I tried
they taught us kanji I can't do that
they treat taught you kanji yep they
touched damn in the in the one semester
yep they tried to cram so much in that
one how many kanji not much they didn't
Mount him there's like three red it's
kanji Katakana and here we go yeah yeah
they did all three in that semester they
tried to teach us like a little bit I
feel like it's pointless yeah that's why
I don't remember any but it was just
like too much the only thing I remember
is how to say like what is your
telephone number which is I think it's
ano TOA didn't understand
thank you I'm equipped to survive in
Japan yeah yeah oh my God that's the
only thing that stuck with me in that
entire semester you'll learn all these
kanji and then like 80 percent of the
kanji you see a bridge and Mountain yeah
like a lot of the time pretty much
obviously there's way more but 90 like a
show many of them are bridging Mountain
yeah it's just Yama it was a lot
yeah I I just don't see how effective
that could be in trying to learn all of
that in one semester no no I mean you'd
have you probably have a better time
just like you know watching anime
probably yeah I feel like I've got more
out of that like I know yeah
as well yeah hentai's good Bible black
taught me a lot the school of Bible the
only Bible I read